leaving out the animation in your title
car doesn't make me forget what you put
me through with that fucking Smurfs
movie Sony 52 seconds of three logos and
I'm already angrier than any of these
goddamn birds I tell you that also this
movie is based on a castle crush ripoff
mobile app that just for that reason
alone I'm going to tack 12 reality sins
on this bitch Birds apparently can't fly
in this movie though a movie has zero
interest in explaining that this bird
per dude hits all the trees but still
somehow avoids breaking the egg wait a
goddamn second read coughed up the egg
after he hit that tree and it launched
at top speed like a missile into the
jungle but somehow Red's able to run
that four down and be in position to
catch it I'm not asking for hyper
realism in my animation Sony but give me
something also bird falls faster than
the egg he's chasing which started
falling before him thereby paying with
my understanding of gravity and that one
scene and Rosencrantz and Guildenstern
are dead that's right kids movie will
invent a way for birds to head external
testicles and to injure them for your
entertainment there's gonna be a
bloodbath isn't it versus actual remarks
to Jason Sudeikis somehow make it into
the movie yeah I'll buy these birds have
found a way to live in a comfortable
somewhat metropolitan environment but
which one of them had the manual
dexterity to lash this clock together
and place the gears and the hands and
can cuckoo did they just order it on
Amazon also this red birds job here in
Birdland is apparently clowns slash cake
deliver because that's a thing don't
tell me a story
just take responsibility the water part
of this whole caper is arguably the
least dangerous thing that happened to
red during his journey this cake is that
movie Charlie goes into Suicide Squad
and graphics for its opening title and
forces me to briefly consider if I'd
rather be watching Suicide Squad as
terrible as this is the answer still no
but it's close I've run my butt off
literally mind you they get the
gluten-free cake movie inspires a
harshly worded blog post from Gwyneth
Paltrow that is not how physics works
[Applause]
you know this movie were about humans
instead of birds he'd have to have
fallen headfirst into a woman's vagina
for this joke to work
at least the movie made an effort to get
some fresh music for the soundtrack even
the fucking Smurfs movie featured
Vampire Weekend judy has mine birds
because it's super funny and you just
didn't realize it is going on here is he
in school and if so why is he hireable
as a clown
why is he painting why was there a mime
hanging out a second ago because this
village this is the one time I'd welcome
a little fucking narration oh man they
dragged poor Sean Penn and it you know
what Sean Penn's been in much worse
movies than this how I'm solid is this
Holmes foundation of a soccer ball
kicked by the Verne Troyer of birds
shakes the entire house so the red guy
is an asshole got it already had it
after he smashed the lake cake delivery
into the customers face but still got it
as this bird waits the literal snot off
his face from the other bird sneeze so
I'm left to wonder how this non
DreamWorks movie got so much Shrek in it
also this movie is trying to show me how
angry this red bird is but in this
instance I mean that Christie's directly
on his popcorn three times in a row
I think his anger is justified here and
therefore nullified is an example of his
anger being over the top also how boxed
in here were this films for writers with
a title like Angry Birds I mean they
almost had no choice right oh yeah Red's
an orphan by the way here's one out of
context scene to show you that little
tidbit laugh labs free from complicated
straps then why do you have this court
also the judge is just one I say I say
away from being foghorn leghorn and what
do you do when you find a weed smoking
anger-management class so this is a bird
animated anger-management funny sight
gag but why is the late riser worm store
ever open at all and considering he's
right next to the early bird warm shop
he's really got to rethink his business
strategy seriously I'm almost but read
could literally walk to the sidewalk and
continue along his way
in fact he's off the street in the very
next shot but this movie has never met a
vapid joke it didn't run into the ground
is one of those yours when birds fly but
they're eating about a bird that can fly
right now I know none of the other ones
on Bird Island can but this seems like
an odd thing to say when looking at the
picture of Mighty Eagle and I'm just
super psyched to be taking this journey
with you starring Jason Sudeikis Josh
GAD Danny McBride Maya Rudolph Bill
Hader Peter Dinklage Sean Penn
keegan-michael key Kate McKinnon Tony
Hale Hannibal Buress this movie is
definitive proof that likeable famous
people still have the price
scene shows us all of the three of an
x-men Quicksilver scene with none of the
technical promise also this tells me
Chuck stole the officer's wallet without
him noticing fine but then Chuck went to
the bar finished at least one drink then
paid for the tab then came back without
the officer ever looking up bullsh
I literally blow up okay I explode like
a bomb
how the hell does bomb do this more than
once are his feathers leased with
gunpowder why doesn't the rest of his
body explode no can do
I just went boom-boom before class
here's another poop joke courtesy of
writers who can't be funny without
bodily functions and might not even be
able to be funny with them so this is
just gonna be a thing huh bomb goes off
and no one in the vicinity is injured
well then I will respond by adding 10
sins because this movie can kiss my ass
there's a new happiness that I'm dying
to see Angry Bird briefly forgets - bird
angrily spirt economy is freaking me out
they have a robust enough economy that
people can afford to spend enough on
hugs to keep a hug trader in business
every time red thinks someone is waving
at him that is not they're always waving
at the same purple hair Brad Pitt type
Burt close can you build a home to the
ocean without ever having to worry about
tides and avian Dominique Rodgers
Cromartie
okay regurgitating into school lunch
bags is maybe the best gag this movie
has to offer even though it's a pupil
joke my real problem is that's literally
the funniest thing in this movie and yet
they still made an entire movie
seriously this is one of the least funny
animated films I've seen since Princess
Mononoke if my name were Bobby calling
bullshit on the reconstruction of this
therapy Hut one night after bomb blew it
to smithereens
my poem is about a hate crime in an
extremely meta moment
Chuck writes about the movie he's
currently in none of the birds are
frightened or skeptical about the
arriving boat they're all just in all
that house took me five years to build
five years I realize you were working
alone because nobody likes you but still
that's a small and simple house and you
should have been able to finish that new
year flat honestly when they pitched
this movie everyone in the room snicker
right
pigs on a boat invade an island of birds
who can't fly only then hahahahahahaha
right
also hour-and-a-half movie about bird
pig video game waits 30 minutes before
even attempting to pig 30 seconds after
first contact these birds are welcoming
us then I'm gonna guess the entire
movie's plot hinges on the pigs taking
advantage of that unreasonable
another did the pig set up this
explosion I know the birds were being
too friendly to strangers but they
didn't all go blind for the last hour
did they how did no one see this being
set up
they destroyed more of the stuff we
worked hard to build red would be
excellent at cinemasins
I realize I'm watching a cartoon but
your giant heretofore unnoticed present
Pig who says birds don't fly
um this movie and basically no one else
this frame of the film's got puns y'all
how many new species does this bird
island meet they meet some pigs and
within hours they're jamming to a house
party being DJ by the pigs does this
culture not have suspicion and anxiety
this forgets a couple plungers placed
where human nipples would be and
instantly goes into a cabaret dance
that's a sin on the movie for being a
fucking perv and another sin on the
movie for this pic knowing what human
boobs are between the overused Black
Sabbath song the truly offensive limp
Biskit cover and the unnecessary Blake
Shelton track Angry Birds just completed
the song turd trifecta as we're clearly
looking at the next day or even later in
the week you got to admire these pigs
prestige level of dedication of the bit
considering it's a foregone conclusion
they'll turn and attack this place soon
pigs invade the buffet and leave red
with only an apple the symbol of asshole
misspent yes he's an asshole
but like Mel Gibson and payback he's an
asshole who was right damn it magic pork
X Excel terrible Pig Instagram pun a
sign this movie is half over and there's
been basically zero conflict this is
what happens when you base a movie on a
paper-thin mobile app fYI you look
delicious my dear fetus flirting
desperate for a gag movie decides that
red painted half a dozen paintings
depicting pigs in a negative light in
this one painting class which I guess is
16 hours long or something I'm pretty
ashamed at what I'm about to say I won't
lie but someone still needs to say if
the pigs are this sailing they could
never have even built one ship that was
capable of reaching bird island because
they are cruel morons this is like the
pig sailing version of that monkey
typewriters thing okay he's going to go
recruit all the birds we know from the
game to go on the offensive attack
against the evil pigs great why did it
take 42 minutes to get here in an hour
and 37 minute movie that's like more
than half the actual movie and we're
still just kind of around here great the
movie is bloating in the runtime by
having these well-intentioned heroes
also be stupid so as to find themselves
inside the TNT boxes without realizing
it the last two minutes of this movie
has seriously been the three leads
making ridiculous noises while climbing
the wrong mountain and then seriously
fast-forwarding through a goddamn
suicide attempt just trust me you don't
need to watch
whether his truck even tired he's been
shown to have amazingly fast abilities
and has zipped all over the island but
climbing this mountain at the same pace
as the other two was somehow exhausting
I know everyone's content down in the
town but you're telling me not one of
these birds has ever been up here there
haven't been any adventurous birds until
now red could have been doing this years
ago instead of clowning and kick
delivering and now synchronized swimming
because this movie is seriously running
out of ways to stretch time to fill a
feature these birds trade spit like
they're sasha grey on a porn set and I'm
just as disgusted here as I was there
wait wait I never torn anything did
goddamnit this movie is already pretty
far down in the toilet in terms of humor
but this is too far and I expect crimes
against creativity charges to be filed
also okay movie has already cut to the
disgusted birds too many times but the
real sin here is that this eagle has the
bladder storage of a large cow LP not so
much the lake of wisdom it's more like
the lake of whiz joke literally wrote
itself when the screenwriters went to
Benihana for lunch in the last five
minutes mighty Eagles gone from a fairy
tale to Rio to a beer gut Kevin James
type animal and even though this part of
the story is racing I'll remind you the
main movie is taking forever why doesn't
he have any visitors or interact with
anyone on Bird Island
it took written his crew less than a day
to get to this mountain the Eagle brings
them into his home and then starts retro
dancing and read says plot and I'm like
what he said is this def pomp
unsanctioned because I think it's not
additionally it's not funny
so there's that the crosswalk Nazi
wouldn't even let read slowly amble down
the street earlier but has no problem
with all these vehicles mad maxing all
around the old lady now all this movies
trees have scales for bark don't believe
me go check this ridiculous 360 shot of
explosions and shenanigans is so
confusing it might as well be in an
Avengers movie
it's time Oh far out in the goddamn
forest was this party set earlier it was
being built right next to the middle of
town but now it taking forever to get
there
I know pigs were using the party as
subterfuge to be able to steal the eggs
but that's a massive amount were there
no expectant moms that we're staying at
home to guard the pigs were somehow able
to not only get the first ship back into
the water after it ran aground but also
to make the second ship completely
disappear use the trampolines in crib up
there in trampolines along the dock
here's Leonard's plan in a nut eggshell
he wants the eggs because they're
delicious
and since their unborn bird fetuses he
knows he can't just come in and ask the
town's vote for them so he spent several
days in a huge expense to build these
contraptions while the inhabitants
staged a party then steal the eggs why
not grab them while everyone's sleeping
or just do the party on the first night
also how do the pigs know how delicious
the eggs are they clearly haven't been
to Bird Island and at least a generation
or two since no one knows who they are
are there other bird islands out there
that haven't made contact with this one
is this movie just a metaphor for
mankind's desire to find
extraterrestrial life and the anxiety
about a malevolent alien race finding us
first no no it's still a big stupid
movie about a phone app okay it's light
out now but the pigs left one that was
still dark which means the birds
continued to party even as truck was
warning them their city burned to the
ground and their unborn children were
stolen
what do we do now what exactly is read
done to become the hero he's
consistently been a dickwad
and while he was right about the pigs
he's done nothing to actually help they
stole your kids I mean who does that
Morgan Freeman we're birds we're
descended from dinosaurs how this does
right now this the only thing they teach
in school is the legend of Mighty Eagle
and they didn't even know there are
other places than bird island I need
some angry flocking Birds roll flocking
credits this thing has sales and a
rudder but is otherwise the least
seafaring vessel I've ever laid eyes on
and it's full of TNT this is a death
ship
I'm convinced the movie budget had 50%
going to animation 40% for the rights to
the songs 10% carved out for casting and
negative 75 hundred percent allocated to
the screenplay characters are given
special powers just in time to rescue
symbol from some curry seriously
wouldn't you rather just be playing this
game instead of watching this
Leonard's binoculars have a built-in
zoom and enhance cliche so these birds
are dead right even in the game the
birds just disappear after they destroy
all the so Red's essentially leading the
entire town into a casual kamikaze
mission Wow
that blows I in a good way it's hard to
pinpoint just how drunk the
screenwriters got after receiving their
advance check for this movie but I'd
estimate between 15 beers and 12 bottles
of tequila drunk this apparently former
super evil gets motivated by rickrolling
the audience and if you didn't have a
reason before to give this movie the
finger but you do now eggs and instantly
there is an army with all the eggs in
their hands fast yellow bird goes
through a room of unexplained cacti
followed by a room where he hits the
tips of a bunch of pig swords and I'm
torn between sending the hilariously
torturous trajectory and sending this
pig village for having such a society
that they have an entire room full of
pigs holding swords up in the air right
next to a room full of cacti they have
an Air Force on standby how much of
their town were they prepared to lose
before unleashing these assholes
[Music]
revisionist history at its finest folks
these pink-ass had pigs stole all the
eggs from bird island and now act as
though the bird attack is unprovoked
Jesus I hate these pigs movie will
simply not stop looking around with
other properties Jesus if they were
going into this territory just show the
dude getting blown by the furry this
entire pig society is somehow evolved to
demand eggs how did that happen how did
they ever develop the taste for eggs
without a steady supply of them no joke
during the second Quicksilver ripoff
scene I rolled my eyes so hard that I
heard something pop wait they're going
to boil all these eggs they're not gonna
scramble any or poach any or fry any
cine sign up just boil them all I don't
think folks that would do this truly
deserve these egg
don't know when to stop oh yeah Leonard
says what everyone above the age of
seven just said to this movie hurting
the enemy away well now I bet he feels
like an ass for holding a lit candle in
a room full of TNT you have annoyed me
for the last time yep
giving one last giant finger to the
audience movie decides to Crystal Skull
its way out of the danger this is way
fewer eggs than what the pigs took
suggesting the king popped a couple on
the way back to his island and making
this movie much more satisfying Lee
gruesome hey you can't save the animal
now breaking a few eggs right wait what
the copper pots all the way over from
there if you're gonna do a nuke the frig
ripoff you have to stay in the new
fridge they are this far away but a
fucking baby spots ants eyes red
climbing out of the rubble a lot
Deadpool you your god damn it this movie
makes me angry you learned your lessons
well hope you live to tell the secrets
you have learned until then it will burn
inside of you these assholes still
haven't learned the lesson about
respecting TNT even after that whole pig
explosion and the hug bird finally gets
to climax which seems like a fitting end
to this movie that feels like it was
directed by Satan himself all these
things look at that what they've been
back long enough to start rebuilding the
town and wrecked a new statue of Mighty
Eagle and open businesses but somehow
built the entirety of Reds house without
him noticing well I'm glad this thing
finally landed this piece of lazy ass
joy of a movie has almost 10 full
minutes of credits that's unacceptable
ever since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes
[Music]
lise you're out of the tree i'm Zangief
i'm bad guy
strong strong backs good excellent
remember this is not a competition
although you two seem to be the best in
the class nobility in poverty I've been
a rich man and I have been a poor man
and I choose rich every time hope you
like it neighbor we didn't have the best
tools or all to know how but we did have
a wheelbarrow full of love under cement
mixer full of hope and some cement
don't spit in his mouth no thanks don't
swallow it